the pm just saying that he's going to
fight the next election does he have
your wholehearted support he certainly
does um if you look at what he's been
focused on making sure that
um the global fight against inflation
and the economic recovery is in place an
energy strategy um safer streets and of
course dealing with
war in europe
on
all these issues the prime minister has
been leading at home and leading
internationally and this trip
to india we are announcing about a
billion pounds of uh i think deals
already done in place 11 000
jobs a trade deal with the largest
democracy in the world
slated to be the third largest economy
by 2050 this is what i think your
viewers will want their leader to be
doing and that's exactly what he is
doing we'll come on to india if we may
but partygate is still the albatross
around the prime minister's neck why
doesn't he just put himself forward for
an investigation by the privileges
committee himself and have done
well i think in many ways if you just
step back a second think about you know
how we do things in this country and
actually an exemplar to the rest of the
world due process is important and what
we are tabling today uh is an amendment
to say actually the right chronology
is that the police complete their
investigation
the cabinet office report the sugray
report is published and then parliament
can decide to refer this to the uh
privileges committee that is the right
way of doing this if you follow a due
process if you uh
just want to play politics with this as
kirsten was sort of
found out yesterday because he
uh whether
probably inadvertently mislead
parliament because you got overexcited
accusing the prime minister suggesting
that the leader of the opposition has
misled parliament well uh david evan has
actually put a letter into the speaker
of parliament and you agree with him
well because he accused the
prime minister of something that he
clearly had no evidence of he accused
the prime minister of attacking the bbc
for their coverage in ukraine the prime
minister did not do that and um
by accusing him of the dispatch box um
mistakenly he should come and apologize
for the people like that isn't it what's
that that's a bit pot kettle black
all i'm saying to you is if you want to
play politics with this then you know
the shenanigans that labour are
attempting today is the route if you
want to follow due process then you
allow the police to complete their
investigation you allow the sue grey
report to be published and then the
privileged committee can look at that
that is what i'll be voting for today
the amendment is the right chronology
and the right way to follow due process
or you could just be the prime minister
and say you know what
i'll just refer myself to the privileges
committee and then all of this nonsense
that we're debating or and taking up all
my valuable time i'll just put it in
train but there is a police
investigation yeah there is already a
cabinet officer
which is already reported in some scale
well but we haven't seen the
abridged version right we haven't seen
this we've seen at least 50 fines and
all i'm saying to you is due process is
the right thing to follow i think you'll
find most of my colleagues who are
fair-minded um who believe uh in uh due
process will vote for the amendment
because it's the right thing to do
this is not the prime minister sort of
saying you know he's the prime minister
he said i'll come to parliament and i
will make a full statement he's come to
parliament after receiving the fixed
penalty notice
given a
wholehearted apology explained his
sentence was a pantomime game we're told
in the 1920s
um just a few minutes i
i think from you know those people who
were present at the meeting um the
detailed questions
and roger gayle is a a
friend and i believe he was there for
three minutes as he quite rightly uh
made clear uh with your interview but
those who were there for the full
meeting so actually the the price dealt
with the substance of the issue and
talked about the economic recovery we've
got a global fight against inflation
people watching this today are worrying
about the energy of course they
absolutely are and the party instead is
being damaged because of party gate um
up until
even before the prime minister was fined
uh
810 local council seats likely to be
lost in the local elections because
people don't trust the prime minister
that's 40 of all the seats that you were
um
putting candidates up for clearly this
is something you can't move on from
until the prime minister grasps it by
the horns well the fifth of may is the
poll that we should quote uh i was with
um activists in wandsworth uh a few
weeks ago and on the doorstep what
people are talking about is the low
council tax being delivered in onesworth
compared uh uh to lambeth and and uh
merton and other boroughs uh uh that are
labor-led um i'm not gonna let you take
me down that route you're gonna get me
an awful lot of trouble when it comes to
the uh local elections that's all i'm
saying what i'm really saying to you is
that ultimately uh uh people make a
choice for who they want uh to lead in
their uh local area government based on
delivery of services and value for money
but partygate clearly does matter uh
you're a polling man so let me quote you
some polls uh in fact you gov that you
once uh were uh owner of joint owner of
uh that's found that by two to one the
public wants him to resign that was just
after the party gate fine was issued
well as i said look there will be polls
on partygate there'll be polls on um you
know the global fight against inflation
the real poll that matters is the fifth
uh of may and actually
on the doorstep people want to see
delivery of services at um value for
money and that's what
conservatives are delivering in local
government and if if you care about uh
you know your council tax and make sure
that your your weekly bing collection
all the other things being delivered for
you then you vote conservatives well i
have got um some more polls for you
another yougov poll talking about how
well the government is or isn't doing i
think we can put it up on on the screen
there 72 think that government is doing
badly on immigration 70 percent badly on
taxation 68 badly on the nhs that was a
yougov poll
so look on immigration um i think part
of the problem has been uh three years
ago we were only getting about 300
people um crossing that that treacherous
illegal
crossing through the channel that's up
to 28 000. so that's uh something that
we're dealing with with the this
historic deal with uh rwanda which i
think is the right thing to do
remembering that these people
i do i tell you for why why because just
to remind our viewers of your background
you know you came here yes uh as a young
man you couldn't speak english you were
an immigrant yes uh if you did that
today yes you would be taken to rwanda
and even if you passed all the tests
you'd have to stay there you wouldn't be
able to come here yes but tiny detail
which is really important my parents fed
a dictator from iraq landed in the first
safe country which is britain uh and
made their life yeah but hold on a
second but we came through a legal route
um and applied for immigration status
and and got that
these
people who are being exploited by
criminals are coming from a safe country
called france that they are already in a
safe country they are coming they're
choosing to be um putting their lives at
risk and being exploited by criminals we
have such a bad relationship with france
now we won't pay them well we slow them
52 million pounds that we've promised to
give to them in order to try to help
with refugees and we haven't given it to
you and the and the and the we are
grateful to john darms and the
intelligence sharing and you know
with that intelligence area has been
responsible for a number of of illegal
crossings being thwarted uh but it's
worth reminding viewers that actually
those illegal crossings also mean
capacity's been taken away from people
who may not be able to make those
illegal crossings who are legitimate
asylum seekers that we need to look
after and we've got a great track record
in doing that in that you know since
2015 i think we've um uh welcomed 185
000 uh people uh to this country from
afghanistan from syria from hong kong
and now from ukraine know as you know
we've got a dedicated team in the
department of education where we're
looking uh to uh place children from
ukraine in the first tranche about a
hundred thousand children is is our
game's not working very well though is
it well i'm very even robert generic um
the former housing minister has said
that he that was it was very challenging
he's now taking in some refugees it was
challenging and and it continues to be
and we get better so you know one of the
things we learned very quickly is having
to go uh to a processing center and get
your visa physically uh was not
necessary you can do it online uh the
numbers are coming up we're almost
touching 60 000 uh people now um and of
course in education we're a tech savvy
you know first world country sure it
should have been much easier than this
look we had to stand this up rapidly um
the the the home office stood up the
processing centers i think within
a week um and started processing the
first visa applications um uh and people
with that evening uh started getting
their uh visas through
we are
we've have a very proud track record of
of certainly in my department of making
sure every afghan child is in school in
education uh we'll do the same for the
ukrainian children we've done the same
for hong kongers um i think that's
important but this rwanda deal is really
important because we've got to break the
business model of these criminals we've
you know we can't israel had a deal with
them didn't they and and that it and it
just didn't work well it's a very
different it was
not like our deal people compare us to
the australia deal and israel this is
very different i think it's the right
thing to do um i absolutely believe that
you know we have to make sure we send a
very clear message to people that it
won't pay don't come here come across
illegally no come here legally right
back to my own story okay right we fled
iraq from saddam hussein came straight
here to a safe country these people are
coming from france that's what i'm
saying you know you were privileged
enough to be able to fly here because
people have to get on dingies that sink
in
they're in france they're in a safe
country they don't circle on that one i
need to ask you about india before uh we
run out of time um are you complete the
prime minister there this morning of
course are you completely comfortable
doing a deal with a country that refuses
to condemn russia at the u.n and the
behavior of putin well india is the
world's largest democracy they are
neutral um on this they know what our
position is the prime minister's taking
a leadership position um in um
making sure we we defend uh the rights
of the ukrainian people they have been
illegally attacked invaded war crimes
are being committed in the ukraine the
indian government is very aware of
arsenal and yet india still won't
condemn them well that india has chosen
a path of neutrality we i'm sure the
prime minister will make very clear what
what what our position is worse than
that they're still buying russian oil in
rupees at huge discounts um and they
obviously have uh weapons deals with uh
russian-made uh weaponry and um it's
undermining the sanctions that that the
most of the western world is trying to
implement
you mentioned uh weapons so around 65 of
the indian uh military uh hardware is
russian we want to change that we want
to uh see india
be looking at buying uh western uh um
defense weapons and other weaponry
that's part of the trade deal i also
mentioned talking about oil and it being
discounted um and
that is in part one of the reasons why
um our energy bills are increasing here
in the united kingdom but we think it's
the right thing to do and yet russia is
not um uh india is not doing that well
let's say india is a world's largest
democracy they've taken it a neutral
position we have taken a very different
position i am certain the prime minister
will will will be
they have in in terms of you know the
votes of the un and and
the position they've taken overall i
think our position is clear on the
illegality of the invasion of uh the
ukraine by uh putin
but they're propping up the putin regime
by doing this well and and this is
something that you know the prime
minister will be discussing really with
this account of course they will our
position is very clear but this trip is
about trade this trip is about you know
building that trade deep trade
relationship um with a country that will
be the third largest economy in the
world uh by 20. it's about doing a deal
with a country that's supporting the
putin regime that is hammering people
day and night in ukraine illegally well
i think that's a misrepresentation of
india's position in terms of you know
they've take chosen a path at the moment
of neutrality and i think um uh
we will make our position very clear i'm
sure the prime minister will will talk
about um uh you know why uh we have
led i hope you know with our uh us and
european uh uh colleagues on supporting
um the ukrainian people the ukrainian
people are um putting up a really good
fight um they're fighting like lions in
in the donbass this battle for the
donbass is going to be crucial uh to re
i hope um uh reminding the prosecution
of of the errors of of judgment that
he's made as much to do as far as your
department is concerned as well are you
going to get more of your civil servants
back to work we are um we have uh
been very clear uh that i want to see
uh departments going back to um
levels of of office occupancy that are
pre-pandemic so pre-pandemic working now
in saying that i also want my teams out
visiting you know nurseries early years
schools colleges and universities
and i think that's the right thing to do
but my absolute commitment is to make
sure that people come back i tell you
there's another good reason is that the
most junior staff can only really
progress if we are together uh whether
it be in uh sanctuary buildings in
london or in our you know great hub in
sheffield we've doubled the number of
people in sheffield we're up to 1500
people now in sheffield and other hubs
in darlington and elsewhere um so we
want people um uh back to pre-pandemic
levels of office um uh occupancy what's
that how quickly oh as soon as yeah
we're we're on it now we're people
people are uh
and i have to say um we've delivered on
skills the skills bill is with the
you're going to have a level you're ever
running you're going to get me in
trouble right
skills bill we've delivered on school's
white paper um to make sure every child
is entitled to a great school uh
wherever they live in their country and
of course family hubs and half of
england's local authorities okay and i
can't end this interview without wishing
him actually the queen a happy birthday
absolutely right thank you oh you've
lost the tl thing is that because
everybody thought it was tour leader no
it was it's t levels and i would have
put on but i've had too many badges i
thought it's important to actually have
the this this is one of those mods
exactly exactly good to see you as
always thank you very much indeed